[Music]
some of these buses have put more than
90 years behind them now they're
cruising the backroads of Lower Saxony
collectors from all over Europe have
brought some of the most elegant and
valuable city buses still on the road to
this very special vintage vehicles meet
it's just fun to fool around with these
old things to drive them keep them going
after all they are pieces of cultural
history I just can't describe it I live
and die for old cars everything rattles
all over and second you need some
muscles to move them around
vegan Valda hooker arrives in a bus by
German carmaker Brenner boar from 1928
the oldest European bus to take part in
the meet in the late 1920s and 30s the
bus carried passengers on its route from
Bad Wharton ferry's railway station to
the center of town it can be quite a
challenge to navigate today's traffic
with yesterday's technology
[Music]
the lingo gets there it's hard to steer
and shifting gears is complicated
you have to double clutch and it doesn't
have any synchromesh gears so shifting
isn't easy you have to know what you're
doing or it'll shake rattle and roll
this one has come the longest way from
Bristol in England it still has
something of the feel of the 1980s about
it
Stuart Shelton has been on the road in
Europe with it for three days so far in
motion no emotion I have to concentrate
on the driving when you drive you always
look at the road either a head or in the
mirrors no matter how pretty the girl is
on the passenger's seat you don't look
at that
one by one the antique buses arrive at
the museum grounds in iron Beck a total
of 70 entries they've come from all over
Germany as well as England Switzerland
Belgium and Austria the organizer of the
meet is the new PS mica automotive
museum its collection has more than a
hundred historical vehicles all
carefully restored by hand
including this 1927 Buick City bus now
it's time for a very special event on
the program a convoy through the
countryside to the one-time Imperial
Benedictine abbey of curvy a unesco
world heritage site all the buses make
the 80-some kilometer roundtrip without
mishap even Xfire chief riddle or /
man's old Buick
[Music]
ah recoup vision about the clutch jerks
a little but that's just an
inconvenience when you get hold of a
vehicle like this it doesn't run you
have to make it Road worthy and that's
really quite an experience
the vintage bus fans take the
opportunity to trade stories and
information where can they get this or
that spare part who knows a specialist
or who can get a rare historical detail
back in order oh well they're getting
hard to find people are dying out there
aren't many left who can restore old
vintage vehicles like a preserved bus
needs a lot of love a lot of time and a
lot of money to keep it going and if we
can't have a lively membership then it
will die out expanding the numbers of
vintage bus fans shouldn't be quite as
hard
the owner operators here are all men but
among the spectators at events like
these are plenty of women to amamiya
more and more women are driving the big
rig trucks and it's quite possible that
one of them might eventually take up
this hobby women are becoming
emancipated so you might see them in
buses like these it's really interesting
to drive a bus like these it's true the
drivers are mostly men but I got my
driver's license on an older model an
old Mercedes 303 so it's nice to see
antique vehicles like these together the
fans here are doing what they can to
make sure these historical buses will be
preserved for future generations
[Music]
you